وبينما يبذل العاملون في المجال الإنساني قصارى
جهدهم لتقديم الإغاثة، فإنهم يواجهون
القصف المستمر، والمخاطر اليومية التي يتعرضون لها
ولأسرهم،
والقيود الهائلة التي تفرضها الطرق المتضررة،
وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي، والحرمان المفرط،
وفي هذه الأثناء يتفاقم المرض والغضب، ويموت
الناس ليس فقط من
القنابل والرصاص ولكن أيضًا  من نقص الغذاء
ومستشفيات المياه النظيفة بدون كهرباء
وأدوية، والرحلات المرهقة إلى
قطع أصغر من الأرض هربًا من
القتال، يجب أن يوقف هذا رفض
قبول حل الدولتين للإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين، وإنكار الحق
في خشب الدولة للإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين.  إن الشعب الفلسطيني
غير مقبول، فهذا من شأنه أن يطيل أمد الصراع إلى أجل غير مسمى
والذي أصبح يشكل
تهديدا كبيرا للسلام والأمن العالميين، ويؤدي إلى تفاقم
الاستقطاب
وتشجيع المتطرفين
في كل مكان،
ويجب أن يعترف الجميع بحق الشعب الفلسطيني في بناء دولته الخاصة.
ندعو إلى وقف فوري
لإطلاق النار لأسباب إنسانية
والإفراج الفوري وغير المشروط عن جميع
الرهائن، ويجب علينا أن نبذل كل ما في وسعنا
لمنع امتداد هذا الصراع
إلى جميع أنحاء المنطقة في الضفة الغربية
عبر الخط الأزرق بين إسرائيل ولبنان
وفي سوريا والعراق وفلسطين.  البحر الاحمر